hi everyone and welcome back to house of
horrors
I'm serene I'm Dan this is Dan so just
as actually ill today unfortunately hope
she gets well soon
so today dan has kindly agreed to step
into her house of course with me dan is
actually also our new editor at the
GameSpot Australia office so it's a
great opportunity for you to introduce
yourself to that stream crowd and today
we are playing a highly requested game I
think this is also one of them games
that has been requested on house of
horrors you know like since the very
beginning condemned criminal origins
silently this game is made up of three
colors brown gray and police car red
I am super into stealth games what I
understand I think the Danvers is
something of a stealth like amnesia mod
I think one of the last house of horrors
which kind of plays off that holy slide
as you have no weapons this guy was
having a tea party but nobody showed up
so he just waited forever Jesus oh here
we go oh I am looking for see me
do you remember what now am i doing I'm
zooming out further than I exist what
did you kill these badasses police
brutality's doing his job
what's mouse button 0 there is no
punching I thought one was the left
quick oh god oh god take it oh oh nice
again oh you kicked him so hard he just
sink disintegrated I kicked him into
another dimension I'm the healthiest
you're still a robust young man
um yeah was that what I missed it Mike
foot popped up yes I'm pretty sure
oh I press space with my phone I'm sorry
it's super interesting to me wish I'm
taking great care not to show my
skittishness right now no you know with
like system shopping by oh oh nice shot
I think he got him in the leg come in
the yes he's gonna bug Sam his legs yeah
I'd better go in
where's he going what a surprise oh no
not the gun yeah I'm gonna pick that up
are you serious
the skies are free yeah you shall it's
not like plot twist your than me I guess
oh god Jess help all right you know what
to do
no no he was like chaos know what I
would like is those 18 health packs like
Ross on the way in that I'd never need
it because there was no instance of
taking damage yeah I strafe like a
creepy man it makes fine crunch sound
he's gonna get back to like the chief
inspector and he's gonna be like so what
do you got he's like well sir I got the
two dead birds in a piece of metal and I
also got a plank of wood with nails you
know they hits dudes pretty do it by the
way so look how high I can kick Oh take
this fire axe and chop your way out dude
he's dead okay he's rag-dolled cuz his
arms gone through his chest does he
think I can't see him oh God
oh I see this mod they're flanking yeah
you actually birth the glove dynamic
environments walking is really hardness
whoa that's cool
chaotic guitar ten just like all there's
a dead bird that's really what is this
guy's deal with birds Oh on the same
path take strange turn wow they're not
very good really sick first can we just
all ruminate on the profundity of that
statement you know push to mission
summary screen is that how you open a
gate in question in the instant I find a
bird NPC and actually get out of this
area that I have stuck myself in oh god
this is gonna there we go boiled by a
milk what is this
where is he pulling this stuff wrong
what
he literally as he was falling yeah it's
like is that is that actually good a
swing animation or is he just as he's
swinging around there was like a damage
you know volume on that thing come on
buddy did you just throw it to the
ground
it was like I don't even need this
that's an invisible one Oh is much
easier than last time
oh did the game change you'll like the
difficulty to accommodate you and des I
think that's what's happened it's gone
like okay buddy I understand you suck at
this game so I'm just gonna have these
guys drop their weapons okay of course
yeah oh we're closed
you're still alive quick I'll finish him
finish him oh wait wait hang on there
okay we missed the save game on the
first menu like oh my god come on
oh he's whistling oh no he's look he's
wrapping this rips thing off the wall
look at that good spotting I didn't even
see that haven't found any birds yet but
you know we've still got some time did
someone from the publisher come down and
they were like look I need you to put
six dead birds in every level because
console gamers really like their
collectibles and we need something for
the achievements so is that a hand in
the bin that's a mannequin hand oh yeah
this beats the sledgehammer
just find it behind this is I have built
a machine specifically to locate dead
bird carcasses this is how hardcore a
collector I am punch this good punch
that was really creepy that was awesome
oh my god oh my god let's kill it it
must die - reloading I can hear em
reloading whoa
business time it's really inconsistent
with how strong you main character is
it's like look I can just push a filing
cabinet open but you know I can't kick
through the glass of an elevator and is
that you like you I don't know what I
look like in negative so I can't really
answer that oh that was gross yeah and
sound like woman it didn't look like
woman hey this suspect Oh new scenery
and yeah this one's really dead this
isn't even a bird anymore like it's just
a collection of bones jackpot
yes okay thank you to everyone who
requested that and thank you Dan for
joining us thank you good fun
hopefully Jess will be back next week
we'll be at our usual time as well feel
free to let us know what you thought of
the game or if you'd like to play any
specific games in future we read all
your comments tweet us with the HHH live
hashtag and we'll hopefully see you next
week
hi everyone